YouTube I I wish I could predict it I'm
constantly amazed by the the sudden
growth in various channels that out of
nowhere one day I've never heard of them
and then the next day they're the
biggest thing out there
I'm Jordan I'm 23 years old I make
youtube videos under the alias
CaptainSparklez it started when I was a
senior in high school I was interested
in watching other people who were making
these gaming videos I wanted to get
better at Call of Duty was the big game
I was playing at the time and so I
decided hey I'm pretty good at this I'll
try making these videos myself I got a
capture card for my birthday and started
in on it it was pretty gradual over time
I kept on making these videos eventually
more and more people started watching
them and it got to a point where I was
in school studying for something or
chemical engineering which would have
been more of a behind the scenes in a
lab type career and I ended up just
deciding hey this is a cool opportunity
to pursue and so I decided to jump ship
to it but I also am trying my hand at
game development I would like to try
starting a company which is what I'm
working on at the moment because I think
it's good to be multifaceted and who
knows how long people are are interested
in me I hope for a long time but may as
well have a plan for something that I
can work on as well if the day ever
comes where I I'm no longer publicly
relevant or something no matter what
your area of interest is there is a way
to make it work as a business or in my
case being like an on-camera personality
but there are plenty people out there
who were there to receive whatever
product you're putting out